salut aujourd'hui nous allons parler
d'un personnage un peu dangereux
beaucoup dangereux on est très dangereux
jack l'éventreur vie d'un personnage
tellement fascinant et emblématique que
certaines personnes pensent qu'il est
aussi imaginaire que sherlock holmes
sauf ses victimes pour aller c'était
bien clair qu'il était bien réel jusqu'à
aujourd'hui son identité n'a jamais été
trouvée jusqu'à aujourd'hui car
maintenant deux généticien britannique
pense avoir trouvé l'identité du tueur
de whitechapel loïc je suis le 10 avril
à cannes avec max bert lola d'ubidyne
célina chez soi ne périsse et pour mon
spectacle spectacle que je venais
rejoint également avec la nouvelle
version pour la première fois à paris du
25 au 28 avril
dépêchez vous il reste plus beaucoup de
place et la tournée continue à biarritz
le roi y deauville strasbourg lille la
suisse la belgique nantes toulouse mais
en bref vous avez toutes les villes dans
le bien dans la description prenez vos
cités
avant de dévoiler le nom potentiel de
jack l'éventreur rappelons quand même
qu'il est et ce qu'il a fait parce que
même si c'est le tueur en série le plus
faible use de la planète
on ne compte plus les livres les jeux
les films qui a eu à son sujet
d'ailleurs je me demande si les ayants
droit de jack l'éventreur il peut
maintenant dire tout ça c'est un nouveau
monde ya sa possible pensez pas en tout
cas on sait pas très bien ce qu'il a
fait et il ya beaucoup de rumeurs une
idée reçue qui circulent à son sujet
l'andrh 1888 la ville la plus peuplée de
la planète pour l'époque
la maladie est omniprésente le peuple
pauvre et les ruines sont pas si sûrs en
seulement trois mois cinq femmes se font
sauvagement assassinée raya des mutilés
avec des organes manquant est quasiment
décapité un petit peu comme un nid quasi
sans tête
ici les poteaux raid cyrielle dans les
idées reçues sur jack l'éventreur il y
en a plein qui pensent que toutes ces
femmes étaient les prostituées mais en
fait pas du tout enfin peut-être y en a
qui faisait ça de temps en temps mais
c'est pas du tout un vrai point commun
et c'était pas du tout avérés et non ce
ne sont pas non plus comme dans les
films de jeunes femmes
il y en a qu'une qui avait 25 ans toutes
les autres étaient quadratus al essaoui
et ben voilà la seule chose qui les
relient vraiment cédé trop pauvre très
pauvre très pauvre il y en a même qui
sont sans abri tous ces meurtres là ont
eu lieu à peine quelques rues de
distance sur la même période il y aussi
six autres meurtres que les gens veulent
rattacher à jack mais faute d'éléments
concordants
on pense que non en fait on n'est pas
sûr parce que quand ils tuent et jack
il avait quand même un petit rituel qui
était humble à nice ce psychopathe après
chaque meurtre avait tendance à envoyer
un petit courrier à la presse et à la
police pour les prévenir avec parfois un
petit organe est un petit mot qu
accompagner tout ça genre par exemple
une fois il a envoyé à ras en mettant un
petit mot à côté qui disait l'autre
morceau je les free je les mange et
c'était très bon signe et jack the
reaper des autorités londoniennes peine
à recueillir des témoignages des preuves
et identifie quand même sept suspects
potentiels tous relâchés
puisque encore une fois il n'y avait
rien qui les faisait finir leurs phrases
par exemple ce qui rendra vraiment
légendaire jack l'éventreur c'est
justement que le mystère est entier
la faire et non élucidées encore à ce
jour enfin peut-être enfin on va voir
après un jeu tison qui peut bon voilà le
seul témoignage qu'on avait à l'époque
c'est un mec qui dit qu'il a vu
un homme avec un long manteau et un
chapeau c'est le seul truc qu'on avait
et loïc est ce que tu peux rien nous
faire un deuxième générique genre son
identité révélée un truc comme ça
ok
eh bien c'est ce qu'affirme jarry loupé
les naines je ne sais pas du tout
comment ça se prononce et un biologiste
ainsi que david miller expert en
reproduction et infertilité masculine
faut savoir que lorsque la quatrième
victime a été retrouvée catherine elle
portait un chalet ce chalet était tachée
de matières organiques un mélange de
sang et de sperme
c'est un indice ou du mois un élément
majeur qui aujourd'hui ne demande qu'à
parler puisqu'on a des techniques un
petit peu plus à penser comme 1888 les
deux généticiens ont donc mené ce qu'ils
disent tu être je cite
l'analyse adn la plus systémique est la
plus avancée à ce jour concernant jack
l'éventreur
quand ils ont dit ça j'avais
l'impression d'entendre un dirigeant de
chez apple l'analyse la plus avancée
ils ont suivi la piste de l'adn
mitochondrial il existe deux sortes d'
adn en ou l'adn nucléaire celui qui est
propre à chacun d'entre nous le plus
étudié quand on parle d' adn on pense à
celui là est l'adn mitochondrial qui se
trouvent dans des organismes nucléaire
minuscule tout petit c'est ce qui
fournit de l'énergie en fait hausser lui
c'est un peu des petites batteries tu
vois pour les pour les cellules cet adn
là est beaucoup plus simple il est moins
complexe
il est des circulaires entièrement nous
sont des brins d'adn pour le nucléaire
celui-là fait une boucle et c'est
intéressant de sa part ça parce que ça
veut dire qui se ne s'habille moins dans
le temps puisqu'il n'ya pas debout ça
peut pas être rongés
cet adn là est en plus simple il
contient forcément moins d'informations
il est uniquement transmis par la mère
enfin ta mère tu transmets le sien ma
mère m'a transmis siens ta mère à lui
elle lui a transmis le sien c'est la
mère qui le fournit mais pas que ta mère
je parle pas de ta mère hockey à partir
de l'adn qu'ils ont trouvés sur le
schale les deux généticien d'aujourd'hui
ont fait des tests sur l'un des
principaux suspects parmi 17 de l'époque
alors pas sur le suspect en lui-même
forcément c'était pas possible donc sur
toute sa descendance connu actuelle
contemporaine ce suspect c'est aaron
kosminsky ce tas très très simple à dire
et
les tests ont été concluants saha match
et ce qui fait darron kosminsky jack
l'éventreur
à l'époque il avait déjà été reconnu par
un suspect qui s'était ensuite rétractée
on sait pas pourquoi et puis la police
d'une part n'avait pas de preuves pour
le garder il n'y avait rien du tout qui
pouvaient l'incriminer et en plus lui
était de confession juive et il avait
peur que y ait un petit truc un
retournement contre les juifs à l'époque
par rapport à ça donc ils l'ont relâché
parce que tu maillard il avait rien
petit précision scotland yard recevait
énormément de pression de la part du
grand public et aussi de la pression
médiatique
l'enquète était très très dure pour eux
et ils devaient faire très attention
parce qu'ils avaient quasiment aucun
indice quant ils ont relâché kosminsky
c'est déjà parce que justement il
n'avait pas d' indices sur lui mais en
plus à ce moment là il y avait eu des
inscriptions à la craie sur les murs du
quartier de whitechapel qui accusait les
juifs d'être jack l'éventreur
c'est aussi pour éviter qu'il y ait des
violences sur la communauté juive que la
police a effacé l'inscription est qu'à
la relâcher certains suspects pour
lesquels de toute manière elle n'avait
pas assez d'indicés à ron était barbier
à whitechapel il arrivait en 1882 en
grande bretagne avec toute sa famille il
était migrer donc il est venu avec tout
son passé avec sa langue natale avec ses
parents et puis avec ses troubles
psychologiques petit délire paranoïaque
schizophrénie aggravé hallucinations
l'hôtel ce qui fait qu il a été interné
et il est d'ailleurs mort à l'asile en
1919 en 2014 y avait déjà eu un livre
enquête sur qui pouvait être jack
l'éventreur qui a été écrit par edward
russell et ils incriminent est déjà
aaron et bien cette hauteur là
ce détective privé passe et un détective
privé c'est lui qui avait acheté le
châle à une vente aux enchères en 2007
et c'est lui qui a fourni le schale o2
généticien justement pour qu'ils
puissent faire des tests aujourd'hui et
peut-être confirmé l' enquête ou 8
supposé déjà au présupposé que que
c'était à rome
c'est clair ou pas cette phrase la
question qu'on est quand même en droit
de se poser c'est est-ce que donc c'est
vraiment c'est sûr c'est aaron c'est le
barbier jack l'éventreur pose cette
question loïc vous vous posez la
question chez vous oui aussi
alors je génériques
alors justement c'est pas si simple
parce que même si les deux généticien
affirme que c'est à rhodes aaron aaron
kosminsky n'arrive pas le dire eh bien
il ya beaucoup de choses à redire sur
leurs méthodes de travail et leur
conclusion tout d'abord l'adn
mitochondrial comme il peut être
transmis que par la mer on n'a pas pu
tester la descendance de jack avec jack
directement au mieux ce qu'on a fait
c'est qu'on a testé des personnes avec
la mère de jack puisque lui étant un
homme il n'a pas pu transmettre cet adn
là et en plus cet adn est très très
simple donc
il est utilisé dans les enquêtes
criminelles pour exclure des suspects
mais jamais pour incriminer
c'est à dire que si on cherche une
concordance entre deux personnes et que
là les deux adn mitochondrial ne
fonctionne pas ensemble on sait que ça
peut pas être lui à cent pour cent mais
si ça fonctionne ça veut pas dire que
c'est la personne
on constate les différences mais pas les
similitudes parce qu'on peut être
plusieurs à avoir cet adn c'est pas très
rare il est pas très complexe
petite précision également avec les
dernières sources que j'ai pu lire très
récemment sur l'adn mitochondrial
pourquoi cet adn permet d'éliminer
certains suspects et non d'en désigner
indirectement comme coupable parce que a
priori 10% de la population peut
posséder le même il y a eu un précédent
en 2002 avec le peintre walter air
stickers dont l'adn correspondait à
celui des lettres de jack l'éventreur
mais donc c'était pas lui mais pourtant
c'est le même adn mitochondrial donc
voilà faut faire attention quand même
ensuite concernant le chan il n'a pas
été bien gardé il est passé de
nombreuses fois de mains en mains encore
aujourd'hui on peut le constater sur des
photos des gens qui le tiennent dans
leurs mains les généticiens et encore
pire
la descendance de l'air les gens qui
l'ont testé l'ont touché l'an tripoter
en plus ce qui fait que ça peut
embarquer du matériel génétique
supplémentaire et ça peuvent fausser les
résultats
quant à l'article que les deux
scientifiques ont publié beaucoup de
leurs collègues le trouve battent les
légers avec plein de raccourcis en fait
à l'intérieur de cet article ils
publient leurs conclusions un tout petit
peu de leurs méthodes
mais ils ne publient pas par exemple les
données de l'adn concernés il ya juste
des petits graphiques avec découvert des
trucs comme ça
donc pour s'en défendre on dit que
c'était pour rendre le résultat
accessible plus grand nombre les
compréhensible et c'est vrai parce que
j'ai pu le comprendre comme ça mais
depuis qu'ils ont publié ça ils refusent
entre guillemets parce qu'ils ne l'ont
toujours pas fait ils n'ont toujours pas
publié une étude plus complète et plus
complexe à destination des autres
scientifiques en tous cas il ya quand
même beaucoup de sa chronicité qui
peuvent tendre à dire que c'est aaron
cosmin kosminsky le coupable alors déjà
il y en a une bonne le fait qu'il était
un peu tard et schizophrène paranoïaque
de sa machin est que quand il a été
interné à partir de ce moment là il n'y
a plus de meurtres de jack l'éventreur
même un bon indice mais il n'empêche que
rien ne le prouve vraiment à 100%
aujourd'hui dans un tribunal j'en ai
parlé avec un ami avocat alors je sais
pas s'il a raison à 100 % mais ça me
paraît crédible si on présentait
exactement la méthode pour l'incriminer
qui a été utilisée par les deux
scientifiques et berry serait relâché
faute de preuves
ça ne prouve rien pour moi le mystère de
jack l'éventreur reste entier quant à
vous il ya quelque chose que vous pouvez
éventré c'est les pouces en l'air les
pouces bleus n'hésitez pas à le faire
vous pouvez également vous abonner à
cette chaîne ne s'est pas encore fait
faites-le c'est important ça prend qu'un
seul clic n'hésitez pas également à
activer la cloche pour ne pas rater les
prochaines vidéos ici vous avez la vidéo
de la semaine dernière ici une autre qui
devrait vous plaire et moi je vous dis à
très bientôt
ciao